okay hey everyone it's Michael Volos
here from orderflows decom and this is
the orderflows market analysis for
Thursday May 4th
2017 and all you Star Wars fans May the
fourth be with you you only get to say
that once a year now it was an
interesting day um big movement in the
crude oil crude o is down about 2 and A2
bucks to
uh around 452 4550 um you know which is
about 9 or 10 months lows amid talk of
over production you know is that a bad
thing well no you know if you got if you
got a car you got to be loading up gas
uh you know it's summer um go for it
now you know again stocks were mixed um
you know stocks have been mixed uh
pretty much you know going back to last
week and tomorrow is the non-farm
payrolls um today we had some data come
out which you know was another batch of
basically very low jobless claims data
and that's you pointing to a healthy
labor market so you know we'll see we'll
see if there strength in tomorrow's
Employment Number um you know one thing
is you know jobs may have been good to
good to have you know plentiful but uh
productivity actually seems a bit weak
um so we'll see uh you know we'll see
what's going to happen obviously you got
the French election this weekend as well
which is going to add a bit
of volatility come uh Sunday night um so
watch the reopen on Sunday said be
careful if you got any open positions
going into the weekend and so the
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures training
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results uh quickly
the tools that I Ed in this present the
orderflows trader the Delta scalper the
Delta surge I may talk about a few of my
other indicators but these are the main
ones that I I like to use in these
presentations um you know the other
indicators are a little bit more
advanced but um quite uh quite potent so
let's uh let's jump in you know the
First Market I want to talk about today
is the uh soybeans you know as I said
it's not a glamorous Market by any
stretch of the means um when when you
tell people you know you trade beans
they think you're some sort of of a
farmer or something and and um you know
but again like I said beans I think is
uh you know one of the contracts that uh
made more millionaires than than any
other contract um you that was probably
up until about uh you know 2000 when
everything was more open outcry pit
traded rather than electronic but now
electronic um you know I do think it's
uh so beans have sort of taken back seat
to some of the other contracts out there
but nevertheless um interesting thing
here in the beans again you know at this
it opens I'll say opens the
reopen for the day session is 8:30 okay
in case you're wondering now we had you
know made these
lows overnight and we kept touching them
um as he started getting into the day
session
97050 you know we made the low you know
roughly before 2 2 a.m. Chicago time now
you know 509 you hit the low again you
bounce up a little bit you've got um a
diver there hit the low again at 740
bounce up again you got a ratio and a
Divergence and you know we close then we
come into 8:30 open and 8:30 we test it
again you got another Divergence so
you're hitting these lows and you're
seeing buying come in okay then you hit
it again at 856 you bounced up off of
this this time you don't have a
Divergence um but this time you shot up
the one you know the one without the
Divergence you shot up uh you know
literally just up to your highs made new
highs and
you this is Delta scalper here you it's
a DOI bar again you know dogee bars are
a bit for me personally i' I've always
found dogee bars to be neutral in
reading the order flow I mean the only
thing that I'll read in it is is the
Delta but I I won't you know that's why
you see no ratios above or below now we
come into these highs you got Divergence
Divergence both of them failed um as we
made new highs we come in we make new
highs boom stack buying and balance
that's what you want to see you want to
see the aggressive buyers coming in as
you're making new highs um you know it
just looks better visually than than you
have here you know what you got you got
to p a combination of um people coming
in saying now we're going to go higher I
want to get in two you could be having
stops as you bre the the new high and
you do come up make new highs by another
you know this is what 979 you get up to
980 now this is interesting at 980 well
here at 977 and a half you do have the
Delta scalper kick in it failed I'm not
going to say oh you know you could have
read it no it it just gave you a bad
signal I say bad signal but the market
you know they were still buying and you
can see it come in and manifested in
this stack buying and balance you get
another chance up here at this high at
980 okay and what happens you got a
Divergence as well up there ratio is one
so it's it's you know order flow is
about you know it's about
average and you start selling
off from 980 boom boom boom Going Down
back down 975
974 um you sort of pause here 973 you do
get the Delta scalper given a buy so
going to move from 970 sorry 980 979
down to you know 973
974 get a little bit of a bounce you
know you got the price rejector you got
Delta scalper you got um point of
control towards the bottom of the bar
you got positive
Delta is this going to be enough to stop
the move maybe maybe not the key is
going to be this next bar now it's
interesting as you're coming down here
you see the Deltas - 500 - 400 -200 - 41
positive 271 so you know that's you're
seeing the market come go lower but the
selling the net selling is you know
getting a little bit smaller um granted
you know it's Market's moving pretty
quick here this is all 10:00 here and
you know it's 10:01 10:02 102 102
102 so this this sharp move down is is
slowing down a bit granted it happened
pretty quick but it's still slowing down
you get a little bit of a
bounce if this bar was green you know if
this bar had positive Delta as well I
would be a lot interested in thinking
this Market can start to Rally again
because what you're seeing is you're
seeing a move down and you're seeing the
Delta's declining right so you're seeing
the net selling basically petering out
and then all of a sudden you see buying
come in but again you know just because
you have one bar with positive Delta in
a down move all of a sudden doesn't mean
the entire move is over right it could
be just a bounce people that got short
above taking
profits could be anything I say anything
could be several things um but then the
selling comes back in negative Delta
boom boom boom we go down lower um get
down to
970 1 and a qu here point of control
right on the bottom of the bar you do
have a ratio bounds low you get a little
bit of a pop again um Delta scoper
giving you a buy here now again you sort
of have this Delta declining - 305 - 266
-8 starts turning up here 123 okay it's
looking good maybe we could start
rallying even here you got positive
Delta but the bar in the price action
tells it it's going to go lower but
already at this area you know I I do
know earlier we had tested these lows at
970 and A5 several times and we're
getting down to you know within a cent
of this low so you know I'm starting to
see some bullish things coming in here
I'm seeing ratio bonds lows you know we
get down here to this
bar um you know it's now the ratio
bounds low and you know so I'm already
thinking you know maybe there could be
some support here we'll see we'll see
you know if it can hold or not again
it's not the low of the day it's still a
little bit above the low but again I'm
I'm I'm curious right now we start going
sideways um you know if you had taken a
off this really you know at best you
would have uh maybe lost about a a penny
or not a penny more like a couple ticks
or maybe broken even um then we start
coming down into the lows now remember
this this level here 971 right where you
got um you know here you got the ratio
bounds low then one tick below it 971
well it's 971 a quter 971 yeah you do
have some volume there I'll say you know
big volume but it's it's it's decent
volume 200 136
125 and when you start seeing you know
these these volumes these these big I
say big volumes but chunky volumes you
know sort of supporting the market if
you get past it right watch out how you
get past it is selling aggressive or you
just sort of getting past it or not like
here we get past it selling in Balance
283 16778 you know you're going into the
lows on aggressive selling that's what
you like to see and you do make new lows
not much um an extra half a Cent and
here you get a Divergence with the ratio
and you do get a little bit of a bounce
up couple cents up here from 9 you know
970 A5 up to 972 and A2 then you get
down to this bar here at
1051 and you have
1053 okay so imagine you know just think
about it you know close your eyes and
imagine what you're seeing here 970 and
actually 969 and 3/4 there's a decent
bid whether it's Shen or Iceberg you
know it doesn't matter you know I know a
lot of people talk about oh you got to
look for these icebergs well you know
what honestly icebergs appear at in most
markets on volumes above 25 honestly I
do not know an Institutional Trader that
does not Iceberg an order that is above
Lots
unless you he really wants to show it to
the market and scare people generally
most Ord are Iceberg um above a certain
size and getting into crude oil most
people that I know that you know again
and I know big Traders at at all the
banks and a lot of the big commodity
trading firms you know sizes above 10
they're already Iceberg it so you know
you coming down here you trade 52 you
trade 25 and you know you're hitting
this level here okay you're pounding
into it there's there's support there
you know what's going to happen as you
get through can you get through this
level um you know it's trading you know
100 200 300 400 500 trades 1,000 finally
gets through it and then it trades 9695
you it's 9692 bid offered at the 3/4
trades
141 and then all the selling is gone you
don't see any aggressive selling below
this level you know as like like you saw
here you saw some aggressive selling
come in you saw these imbalances so you
know all these people that were selling
it trying to get it to go lower you know
they're not able you know they get it
lower they get it lower byy a tick
where's the aggressive sellers where's
the other Traders coming in here to
start selling you know where's the big
guys coming in say I got to sell you
know we're breaking this is important
level I got to sell some more they're
not they're not there and you know for
breakout Traders you know people
thinking hey we're making new lows here
I got to sell it well you know anybody
that's doing that you know thinking hey
you know we traded 900 there if we get
through this all hell is going to break
loose yeah it might it might but you got
to watch what's going to you know what's
going to happen in the at the next price
level instead you see more buying come
in 141 you 141 doesn't look like much
when it's compared to a th000 but you
know it's it's a decent amount in this
market and you see it's just a support
level you know now you know there's
buyers here and you even come down you
hit this level again it trades five and
then we get this nice rally all the way
up you know from 970 up to 974 A5 you
got a ratio balance low up here telling
you there stopping volume at the end of
this move this ratio up here and you
come off a little bit here and go
sideways going into the close for the
day now what I just talked about you
know with the Deltas I'll show you a
better example I'll say better examp
I'll show you a nice example that
happened you know during the trading
room session um it was in The e-
Minis and you know it it was very
interesting I was talking about it in
the room when we were coming into the
lows and you was on the four range chart
now again you know it all depends you
know what you're seeing on a chart
depends on you know what time frame like
I have a 10 range chart open I have a 4
range chart open and it was you can see
it happening on the four range you
didn't necessarily see it happening on
you you didn't see it happening on the
10 range but I'm just going to talk you
through it um this was this morning just
before uh 9:00 okay so you know cash
opened in the snps and you know we
opened around
862 you know roughly sold off over the
next 30 minutes went into the lows here
now this sort of structure here you know
this is
um you know the beauty of order flow
right it's giving you information people
always you know hear me talk and say oh
you're trying to pick highs and lows no
I'm not I'm reading the order flow and
if it's telling me you know hey the
market is starting to
bottom then okay the Market's starting
at bottom I'm looking to buy you I'm not
trying to pick lows specifically the to
say yeah I pick the low or anything like
that or I picked the high you know I
said I'm not predicting that instead I'm
reading what's coming in in the order
flow and taking advantage of it and the
Delta is something that you know really
helps you out in that sense so we're
coming into these lows right we had just
you know from 86 and2 we're trading down
now we're trading down to 81 and A2 82
and A2 and look you got Delta - 1497 -
1419 so it's getting lesser granted
there's not much difference between 1497
and
1419 and then - 636 and then positive 41
positive 1197 so what do you see here
you're seeing you know even though these
are kind of biggish Deltas negative
Deltas to be honest it's still declining
you know -400
-419 - 600 and you get positive right on
the bottom you know a small positive
some more you know it's not like a big
one which I'll show you in the 10
range but you know selling is declining
as you come into the bottom we're
starting at to bottom and while in this
bar you had a mid mid Delta of minus 882
it ended up at minus 41 so you had
selling early in the bar right it was it
was looking like hey we might go lower
we got strong you know we got 800
negative Delta but what happens buying
comes back in the bar closes up final
Delta of 41 next bar
$197 okay you that's what you like to
see you like to see selling you know
drying up so to speak getting weaker but
buying starting to get stronger so you
know if you're getting long in this bar
you know where you have actually you got
a couple things you got the delta surge
you've got the um a ratio this previous
part you did have the Delta scalper give
a buy actually and what happens is you
know so from you know 82 82 and a
half you know what does the market do
boom it trades back up to 86 and a half
you know that's you know that's within
that's the move it takes 30 minutes and
to make but you know that was it was
something that I I sat there explained
it to everybody in real time as it was
happening this is ideally what you like
does it always happen no um you know
does it always happen at every high and
low no but when it does you know it it
looks beautiful I mean that's what you
want to see um in the
markets so you know that was those are
the two interesting things you I'll be
honest after um after
11:00 I I didn't really I didn't look at
the markets um I had some other stuff to
do but um again you I'll going keep this
one a bit short today with those two
examples and I said you know again
tomorrow's not Farm payrolls and uh the
weekend is a French election so it'll be
interesting Sunday night um you know you
know if you're a market junkie like
myself you know you'll you'll have
you'll be sitting in front of your
screen watching uh the market
reopen and then uh see what the
fireworks are in the S smps and
obviously uh when Europe opens um you
know again it'll it'll be very
interesting to see what happens
okay actually you know what before I go
I'll talk a bit about the five years
five years were interesting as well um
honestly and it's something that you
know you could only get if you're
reading the order
flow and what had happened was in the
morning 7 8:00 You' come down into this
low area down here um basically between
1118 and a half and and 11802 and A2 and
there is very decent volume in these
this these two bars here 830 to 848 um
between you know 01
and one and a half there's about 40,000
contracts traded here you know right off
this the low is here at dou o and a
quarter but at o and a half 3/4 and 01
you got about 40,000 Lots being traded
now again if you don't believe there's
value and Order flow just looking at
that tells you hey there is support
there there is buyers um both you know
passive buyers and people buying the
offer you do have sellers of course I
mean obviously you can't have a buyer
without a seller but you know you're at
your
low what you're interested in is are
there a lot of buyers and yes there are
a lot of buyers here um you know just do
the math you know 6,000 6,000 that's
12,000 plus the residual so 13,000 um
23,000 um you know 31,000 and then you
got another you know four
7 you it all adds up to around just over
40,000 so what's going to happen are we
going to get through this level are we
going to hold that's why I drew these
lines here because I wanted to see what
was going to happen
now again I was talking about you know
if we're going to Rally where we going
to Rally to I do know we have some
volume up here just you know maybe about
a a tick higher yeah 1611 1254 2700
4,000 6,000 so there is some volume up
here and I felt you know can we get past
this or not and I saw this some price
rejection there so I do know that there
was some volume up there that we can't
necessarily get past we came back down
again you can see some decent volume
being traded here 4,000 7,000 6,000
7,000 6,000 And We Just Bounce Around in
here boom boom boom we start putting in
some more volume right above these
levels
1801 and 01 and a quar and then you
finally start you know even here again
you know
I honestly you know I wasn't expecting
to see this this heavy volume here
10,000 13,000 18,000 I I did not expect
to see that when I was talking about
this earlier I just expected to see more
volume like this that we're seeing 4,000
7,000 6,000 which you know sort of lined
up with this heavy volume earlier so we
put in this volume here so what's going
to happen can we if we get past this I
think the market know what's going to
happen can the market go up yeah if we
get past it or if it's going to hold as
resistance the market will go down just
like here you know if we get past this
this level in the next bar I expect the
market to to fall over or if we get past
this level up here you I expect the
market to rally and boom what happens we
start getting past it aggressive buying
you know 4,000 here you know 8,000 there
and we just you know
11,000 we we get up you know we get on
up and we we sort of hold above this
this upper band here which you know this
was your resistance before now it's your
support and this is where we are right
now in the evening session so this was
you
know a decent move you know it's a five
years one tick is you know it trades in
quarters so one tick is you know
$781
um and 5 years isn't necessarily a
market that you get a lot of movement in
you know so if you could get
uh you know anywhere between four to
eight ticks on a move that that's good I
mean sometimes you can get a lot more
it's you know it's what I call it's like
one of those sleeping giant sometimes
when it starts to move you can get some
massive moves in it um and it's a good
contract you know for people that are
relatively new to trading that um you
know want a little bit more safer
contract because you know to me it's
what I call a safer contract because it
has a lot of volume in it so getting out
is not going to be a problem the only
issue you may have is you might not get
the big moves that you like but you know
that that's the trade-off but it's a
it's a good contract to to sort of cut
your teeth on you know if if you're
looking for something to trade that
doesn't have a lot of volatility of
course I say doesn't Michael doesn't
have a lot of volatility I can trade it
and then boom you know it moves uh two
basis points um the next day in general
it doesn't you know keep in mind you
know if if you're trading in an interest
rate contract and there's a Fed speaker
like tomorrow you also got Janet Yellen
speaking be careful and if you're
trading interest rate you know you're
trading a jobs number around you know
around an inflation report or anything
like that be careful because you know
inflation and and interest rates you
know are are you know the numbers you
know move the infl inflation numbers
move interest rates so you know
understand what you're trading don't
don't think that well Mike said you know
it's a low volatility market and it's
always going to be low Vol no you know
it could pick up at any point and start
moving you know it's it's your job as a
Trader to recognize that so you know
those are three things um that were very
interesting in the markets today and you
again I try to keep these short I don't
want to go on too long for for uh
reasons um
you know people I think get bored
sometimes with what I have to say and I
tend to go off track sometimes so thanks
for watching this to learn more about
orderflow trading and the software visit
my website ORF flows.com um thank you
and I'll catch you hopefully tomorrow
I'm trying to get a video out every day
um you know just you know instructional
you because every day there's something
interesting to talk about in the market
you know orderflow is so complex that
sometimes people feel overwhelmed but
you know when you learn the basic Basics
you know how to read an orderflow chart
how to read um imbalances how to read
Delta you know what seems complex
becomes you know very easy and then like
I say it's like driving a car for the
first time you don't know what the [__]
you're doing right um I know me
personally before I drove a car I drove
a tractor okay but driving getting
there's a big difference between driving
a car and driving a tractor and uh to be
honest I was a bit I was a bit scared um
I don't want to say terrified I was just
a bit scared because you know it's me my
driving instructor
and my best friend and one of my friends
brother you know those that was my group
in the car but
um you know I
thought you know I thought hey you know
what I I could uh I could I could kill
everybody but hang on sorry about that
but then um you know just anyway you
know and after after a while right you
know with driving it became second
nature you know um you know I didn't
need someone to tell me you know uh slow
down use a turn signal you know all this
stuff becomes second nature and you know
that that's what you know trading should
be to you um you know reading the market
things like that things I just explained
to you should become second nature you
should be able to internalize that and
see that now again and it's not
something that you have to sit down in
front of the screen and you know try and
decipher I mean it should be clear if
it's not clear then don't take the trade
you know it's it's one of those things
like when I was working at JP Morgan you
know we'd always have to do these ethics
trainings every 6 months you got to do
you know anti-money laundering you know
they ask you these questions oh if a
person comes to you with a suitcase full
of cash should you take the money well
it's one of those questions you know
it's so obvious the answer is so obvious
that if you have to even think about it
you know it's wrong and you know same is
with trading know if you got to sit
there and try and justify taking this
trade you know should I take this trade
you know the way because the way the
Delta is no you should know by looking
at the Delta scene as decline hey yeah
you know this looks good I should be
taking that that's the point you want to
get to in trading and you know
that's why I do these videos um to help
people get to that point you know people
you know write to me they say Hey you
know it's all making sense to me you
know that that's what makes me go on and
and make these uh videos you know I do
get some hate mail but still that's fine
you know there's always going to be
haters I don't care you know people
could tell me oh Mike you're a stupid
idiot you don't know what the hell
you're talking about I don't care you
know these people are Anonymous to me
you know they're Anonymous to the world
they like to sit behind the keyboard and
critique everybody they don't go out put
out anything of their own and you know
share anything with their own you know
I've I do this because you know I want
to teach people um you know whether you
buy my software or not if you do great I
get a little bit of money from it but
you know really my goal is you know in
life I feel like it's my obligation to
teach people what I've learned about
trading because you know when I started
out in trading I I thought I knew
everything it turns out I knew nothing
and by meeting other Traders you know on
the floor off the floor um working at
ctas um you know I dealt with a lot of
the big ctas you know John Henry when he
only had 100 million I remember when
John Henry had you know $100 million and
that was like wow he's got $100
million that was a lot of money you know
for a CTA or fund to get an allocation
of $10 million back in the 90s was a lot
of money now if you're a hedge fund and
you don't have $100 million you're not
even on people's Radars um you know
that's how the industry has changed and
it is it's grown you know I got luckily
I was fortunate to get in at the time
when it was still I'll say in its
infancy but you know still sort of
growing you know and and you could
depending on where you worked you did
have access to to brilliant Traders so
anyway guys um that's it for today and
hopefully I'll get another video out uh
tomorrow thanks